[MUSIC]
It's an incredibly exciting
time to have you here.
There's so
much going on in the auto industry.
And before we delve into
the trends within that,
and potentially your personal career,
and the leadership that you've shown, it'd
be great to look at the space as a whole.
And it seems at the moment there's a sort
of existential threat where the need,
and indeed the desire to
own cars is coming down.
How do you lead such a huge
iconic company in that context?
>> Well, I think, obviously we do a lot of
research to understand what's happening.
We're definitely seeing people
are deciding to buy vehicles later.
Depending on where they live.
And if you put the customer in
the center of how you look at this,
it doesn't surprise me that,
if you're in New York City, and
you pay a lot of money for a car, and
you pay a lot of money to park it.
When you get it out to drive it,
you're in stop and go traffic.
When you get to where you want to go,
you're going to pay a lot of money
to park it if you can find a place.
And so, you start to look at all
of those customer pain points.
And you start to say, people
are still going to need to move from
point A to point B, but depending on if
they're in a dense urban environment,
what are they going to
need to travel with them?
Are they a single individual?
Do they have three children and
a Pack 'n Play?
So I think we try to look at and say,
let's really understand the customer.
And let's understand how we
can create value for them.
And how we can provide new
experiences that are better for them.
And that kind of drives us on how we make
decisions about what we invest in and
different concepts of why we did
the alliance with Lyft, why we bought
Cruise Automation, why we started
our own car sharing program, Maven.
It's all with this intent to make sure
that we're looking and saying, how do we
provide the most value for the customer
as they get from point A to point B?
>> Right, and
in these times of sort of quick change,
presumably that requires a change of
behavior equally at General Motors.
And it's over 100 years old,
over 200,000 employees.
I'm sure you know these stats.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But more seriously, historically,
the focus has been on a long
product cycle, on lean operations,
not on taking risks, on iterating quickly.
As we move from a hardware centric
world to a more software focused one,
how do you change the behavior to become
more dynamic, more entrepreneurial?
>> Well, you make a really good point and
we've invested a lot of time in that.
People have this 100 year
old view of General Motors.
And one of the stats that I throw
out that usually surprises people is
almost 40% of the employees,
the salaried work force,
has been with the company
less than five years.
And so, there's a lot of new talent
that has come to the company.
As we've done that, we've kind of mixed,
remixed the shift of.
There used to be a lot of people
who worked on body structures, and
now we have a lot more software
engineers in the technical area, so
we've really managed how we shift
the skill set of the organization.
Because even if you take
the traditional car, ten years ago,
when you look at a car, it had a radio,
it maybe had some systems on it.
But now, every vehicle we make,
even say the most base vehicle,
has tens of millions of
lines of code in it.
So we've been making that shift and
have a lot of new talent that
has come to the company.
But then the second part of your question
is, we're a long development cycle.
If you start from a blank computer screen,
not a piece of paper, you're really
going to be on a four to five year
development plan to put a new
car into the marketplace.
But when we're doing a new offering for
Maven, it's on a week cycle.
It's how quickly do you create the
software to add the new functionality to
the app?
And so,
we've really had to challenge ourself to
know when we need to move at
a vehicle development cycle,
because the average of
a car is over 11.4 years.
So we're making a product that's going to
be on the road for a very long time,
and safety is an overriding
priority with that.
But yet, in different aspects
of our business now, what is
the minimum viable product to put forward
that will really start to add value?
So we have to be working,
we talk about working at both speeds.
One of the great things was
acquiring Cruise Automation.
Because what we've done with Cruise,
and we've now given them responsibility
not only to develop the artificial
intelligence, or the specific software for
autonomists linked into the major
technical resources of the company.
But we've also given them the
responsibility for commercialization and
we have a, I'll say a very thin line of
a handful of people that they go to when
they want to leverage the vast
resources of General Motors.
There's like a pretty hard wall with the
big company wanting to go into the startup
because we don't want to overwhelm
them with help and slow them down.
And so,
it's really allowed us to kind of learn,
I'll say at startup speed,
how to run a major initiative.
A very important program that we're
working on from an autonomous driving
perspective and
we're able to start to infuse that type of
thinking into the broader organization.
So the added benefit of acquiring Cruise
was not only the wonderful technology and
the talented people, but
it was also just driving the whole
company to work at start up speed.
>> And speaking about autonomous cars,
I think we all acknowledge now
it's a matter of when not if.
What should we as, sort of, citizens be
most excited about in that transformation?
What should we be most concerned about?
>> I think we should be most
excited is safety, because 96%,
if you look at the latest statistics, 96%
of all fatalities, and this is US data,
because it's readily available,
are due to human error.
And so,
as you get into autonomous vehicles,
you are going to be moving to a much safer
way to be moving from point A to point B.
So I think that's one of
the most significance.
And also, if done well,
is more convenient, gives you time back.
You can be doing other things in
the vehicle, having different experiences.
We call it a vehicle, but
whatever we want to call what
moves you from point A to point B.
I think worried about is, I don't know
if the customers necessarily were.
But I think it's also, I wouldn't call
it a worry as much as an understanding.
Is that, for a very long time, autonomous
vehicles are going to be interacting with
vehicles driven by humans.
And it's going to be moving
to a much safer place,
but that doesn't mean that
everything is going to be perfect.
Nothing in life is perfect.
No software program is infinitely perfect.
And so I think understanding how we
make that transition in today's world,
I think will be important, that we spend
some time educating but also helping
people to understand what the technology
is capable of and what it's not.
And especially where we're going to be,
for a very long time,
we'll be in a world that has both.
>> And you mentioned the significant
investment you made in Lyft earlier.
I think at one point there was even
talk about potentially acquiring it.
But what's the game plan there and
particularly give them what's happened
more recently, how do you think
of trying to lead to Uber?
>> Well.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] That's lift
subjective I would imagine.
The way we look at it and why we did
the alliance is we believe that autonomous
driving for end consumer will first
happen in a shared environment.
Now, why is that?
A one is because as the vehicles,
you first put the vehicle out,
A, we want to own it until we go through
the rapid cycles of getting the sensor
across town, there's going to be costs.
So it's going to make sense to have
it in a A shared environment but
also because the vehicle will
start with limited capability.
Right now we're limited on how fast the
vehicle could go based on how fast we can
process the date that
coming in from the sensors.
You know that will change and
that will change rapidly.
So what will happen, the cost curve will
go down as the capability curve goes up.
How does it manage a tunnel?
How does it manage different snow and fog,
and all the other different elements?
And so, I think, that as we look at it,
that is why it was so
important to have an alliance.
We've actually learned a lot about the
ride sharing space through our alliance.
But very important because that's where we
think the first major opportunity is for
autonomous vehicles.
>> So maybe summing up all these
kind of first few questions,
what does General Motors look like
in ten years' time, 20 years' time?
>> I don't think anyone knows.
But I think my view, and
what I work hard every day to make sure,
is that General Motors is
leading the transformation.
Because when I look at
the assets that we have.
Not only the deep technical talent
of doing, again, machines and
technology platforms that are on
the roads for more than a decade.
And leading in how do we focus on the
customer to make sure that it's not just
technology because we can.
But how do we solve real issues?
How do we make the world better
from a customer perspective,
from an environmental perspective,
from a congestion perspective?
And so I believe that all the assets we
have that we have a unique ability and
responsibility to live
that transformation.
To do that exceptionally well and
improve the whole transportation space.
>> Okay, the political environment
has also seen significant changes.
A big part of President Trump's campaign
was bringing jobs back to the US.
General Motors has manufacturing
hubs all over the world.
You're also part of his business council.
How do you sort of balance that and
how do you think about bringing all
manufacturing jobs back to the US?
>> Well, I think first, our general
philosophy is we build where we sell.
And in the United States, for example,
70% of the vehicles we sell in the United
States are built in the United States.
If we look at just total number of
vehicles built here versus sold here
it approaches 80%, so
we do have a lot of jobs.
We have over 100,000 jobs
in this country alone.
So, part of it was making sure
people understood our industry.
My responsibility is to
manage the company and
deploy capital in the best interest
of our owners, our shareholders.
And so I've got to look at that and
make sure.
It's easy in the world to say,
I'm going to build a factory here and
I'm going to bring a bunch of jobs here.
But if that's not sustainable, if that
wasn't the best decision for the company,
it's a very temporary situation.
You have to have a strong, vibrant company
to provide jobs to have job security and
provide jobs over the long haul.
And I think that's what the goal is here.
So I think we work on, how do we make
manufacturing more competitive here?
How do we take away,
across the globe there isn't necessarily
a level playing field and
what can come in versus can be exported.
So there's a lot that we can work
on that's going to improve jobs.
But the foundation of it has to
be good business economic sense.
Otherwise it's not sustainable and
in the long term it's not good for anyone.
>> Then sort looking specifically,
I have one of President Trump's tweets.
It said General Motors is
sending Mexican made model of
Chevy Cruze to US car dealers
tax free across the border.
Making US [INAUDIBLE] pay big border tax.
[CROSSTALK]
>> I recall that too.
[LAUGH]
>> Yeah,
they never sound as good
when you read them out.
>> [LAUGH]
>> General Motors is clearly not alone
in facing tweets from President Trump.
Given particularly the lack of clearly
defined policy that we've seen,
how do you react to a tweet like that?
>> Well, I think the first thing
is don't over train at it.
Because if you step back and say, okay,
his message is jobs, that's pretty clear.
We were within, I don't think it was
an hour before that tweet came out.
We were able to put the facts on that
specific vehicle that yes it's built in
Mexico but, then it becomes
the economics of building cars.
We probably sell, I don't know,
less than 10,000 of those
vehicles in the United States.
Because a hatch,
it's a segment that people want, but
it's not a dominant segment.
And that's true for most countries.
So, placing that business
in Mexico with all the free
trade agreements they have allows
you to offer that vehicle.
If you said, I can only offer it if I
build it here, I wouldn't capitalize it.
So, it wouldn't be available.
And so
part of it was just explaining that,
explaining that the Cruze sedan
is built in Lordstown, Michigan.
And a factory is dedicated to it.
And I think that pretty much subdued that.
But I stepped back and said, okay I'm
not going to over train on the tweet.
I'm certainly not going to
get into a tweeting exchange.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Let's put the facts.
>> I don't have those tweets that you-
>> [CROSSTALK] Yeah, I do.
But if you think about it,
I step back and said, okay.
What is the real message?
And let's now work constructively
on trying to create more jobs.
One of the things I'm really proud about
at General Motors is with the 100,000
people we employ.
Those are good middle class or
better jobs in this country.
And I'm really proud of
the jobs that we provide.
So let's look at how does it
make good business sense for
us to do more of that as opposed
to responding to a tweet.?
>> Got it and I guess then more formally
lots of potential trade policy coming up.
Is there anything that you're thinking
will benefit General Motors substantially
or workers in the rust belt?
>> I think workers across the country,
I think getting a level plain field,
I think that's how we can really ask.
We shouldn't ask for
an advantage that is artificial.
Again, my opinion,
let's have an equal playing field and
then I can create more jobs
if I sell more vehicles.
If I make more vehicles
here that I can export.
Because it's not a 10, 20, or 30% tax
as they're sent to another country.
I mean,
our main message is a level playing field,
and then let us compete,
and we'll bet on us.
>> Got it, and then we saw that some CEOs,
like Travis from Uber.
Obviously chose not to be part of that
business council in the end after
a reaction from their user base.
Was that something that
crossed your mind as well,
given with parts of your customers,
it's an unpopular administration?
>> First of all, it's our administration.
I have voted in many elections, and there
have been times the candidate I voted for
was elected.
And there have been times that
candidate hasn't been, but
it then is our government.
And so when you're asked to serve and
with as important as our industry is
to the country and jobs and what we do.
To not take the seat at the table
if it's offered to you,
I just think it is a missed opportunity.
And so when I represent the company and
to have that voice,
into the government, I think,
is vitally important.
And I think it's proven
to be very important for
us to communicate a very
complex supply chain.
As it related to the border tax initially,
when those conversations.
Or the fact that there wasn't a level
playing field across many countries.
That can send vehicles here with no tax or
to talk about job creation and
job training.
There has just been a whole host of issues
that we have been able to have a strong
voice into it So to miss that opportunity,
I wouldn't consider that.
>> And you mentioned that
having a seat at the table,
would you ever consider a more
permanent seat at the table?
>> [LAUGH]
>> I think I just
answered that question about a week and
a half ago.
But I've been at General Motors for
37 years.
There is just so
many exciting things we're working
on with transforming the industry.
That's where my heart is, that's where my
passion is and that's where I will work.
And I think I can contribute,
if we execute what we're working on,
I think that we can really contribute
to the country and to the globe.
because we do business in many countries,
so I think that's where I belong.
>> Makes sense.
I'll change my track.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So one of the other things is you,
obviously, why are you considered one of
the faces of successful women in business.
There sometimes appears to be
an expectation that will make you
a champion of women in the workplace.
Is that ever something that's
frustrating or how do you handle that?
>> Well, I guess I'd like to be
a champion of people in the workplace.
because I believe, fundamentally that
you'll have create the best experience,
have the best results when you engage
the hearts and minds of your people.
So that's the way I look at it.
Clearly, if I can be a role model for
young women to want to pursue a career in
STEM, which I think is so
vitally important.
Or for them to say I'm going to aspire
to do this because I've seen her.
And she did it, so why can't I?
And if I can provide that role model,
that makes me extremely happy.
In my first year on the job,
I had somebody come up to me and said,
Because of you, my daughter has
chosen to study engineering.
And it was like one of the best
comments you could get.
And so, for sure that is very meaningful.
At General Motors,
because you can't say diversity is so
vitally important for
the success of our company.
And it's not something that you can say,
well, I did it and it's done,
it's something that you
continually work on.
I champion a group of the most senior
women, so the top 35 women in the company.
But it's really for me, it's getting
them to say, okay, don't come to me and
tell me everything that's wrong.
You're a senior person in this company.
Go tell me how you're going to
solve those problems, and
what you're going to do to make it better.
And we now meet three to
four times a year, and
work on what are some of the issues
with women and diversity.
because what I found earlier in my
career as I worked on diversity,
is generally a lot of times when
you solve these issues from women,
you solve these issues for everyone.
Because a lot of time men have the same
issues, or if it's a minority issue,
or whatever it is a lot of it can
get solved with solving the women,
the issue that's termed the woman's issue.
And so I'm dedicated to that.
But I also believe it's you want to win
the hearts and minds of your entire team.
>> Right, and if we now look back to
sort of the start of your career.
You came through as a co-op
student with General Motors, and
spent 37 years rising to the top.
A lot of us now,
I think don't expect to have such
a long term career at one company.
What would be your advice for
us in considering that, and
if you're reviewing resumes now?
How'd you think about someone that's maybe
gotta wider breadth of knowledge versus
a depth of knowledge, and someone that
stayed in one place for a longer time?
>> Well, you meet people who have breadth
and depth, depending on what the role is.
So I look for that.
I don't necessarily look and say,
this person's been at four companies.
And this person's been at one.
I want to sometimes understand,
because if the person's been at
four companies, why did they leave?
And a lot of the times they leave for
very good reasons.
Sometimes if you get to a point where,
well I had an issue here, then I had
the same issue here, and I had the same
issue here, and I had the same issue here.
Maybe you're the issue.
[LAUGH]
>> And
so, I kind of want to probe
a little on that, but
beyond that, that's not important to me.
It's really what the skills,
and abilities,
and experiences that they bring,
and the leadership that they bring.
I've been at General Motors for 37 years,
and I wouldn't say when I started and
graduated as a co-op student
that I was going to be here.
I didnt have this plan, well I will
be at General Motors for 37 years.
I kept having great
experiences put in front of me.
They sent me here.
We were just talking in the back that,
when I first came back from the business
school, there had been a lot of change in
turmoil and I didn't have the best job.
And it wasn't one of those
that I was passionate about.
And fortunately in about
a year's period of time, and
especially by two,
the situation changed and I chose to stay.
So I always believe in your career.
Life's too short to work for a company or
be in a position that you don't love.
Now, work is work,
I had this funny text from my nephew,
who's now graduating from a BBA in
the business school at Michigan.
And it was his first job,
and he texted me.
I'm sitting at a computer and I've got to
do all this work on spreadsheets and I,
it was kind of like, this isn't much fun.
I said, yeah that's why they call it work.
[LAUGH]
>> You're going to have to work and
not every days,
you can't measure your career on everyday.
But if you find yourself after
six months after a year that,
work is not challenging.
Or you don't enjoy it, or
you're not energized by it,
you should probably find
something else to do.
Again because life's too short.
I am fortunate after 37 years, and again
it wasn't always just a straight line,
there were ups and downs in that curve.
But I've been offered tremendous
opportunities which you can have at a big
company, like a company
like General Motors.
To have worked in communications,
and HR, and run an assembly plant,
and led the machinery equipment, purchase
for the globe, and product development.
I feel like I've had a bunch of careers,
they've just all happened to
have been at General Motors.
>> So having had two years at the GSB, and
to have enjoyed the life in California,
the transition back to Detroit, was that-
>> [LAUGH]
>> Was that an easy one?
And I guess as graduates again here,
Detroit is probably not one of the places
that a lot of us are looking for work.
How'd you think about that now?
What are the positives we're
missing about Detroit?
>> [LAUGH]
>> Well, there are so many.
First of all, it was easy for me to go
back home because that's where my husband
was, and that's where my family was.
And I'm a pretty family-oriented person.
So if General Motors had said, hey you
could stay here, I probably had said,
well unless my husband's coming
here I want to go there.
But again, family oriented person
at the time, my parents were there.
And so, that wasn't that hard a decision.
Now I have to admit one of the reasons
I love being on the Stanford advisory
board for the GSB, as well as the board
of trustees, I love the Bay Area.
And, one of the things that I, and
Glen will remember this when we designed.
We actually do a custom program for
our top leadership.
And one of our third,
I think completing our third cohort now.
It's a program that runs a year
with four different weeks.
And when I first came to the school I
said Silicon Valley doesn't have the, or
Palo Alto, you don't have the lock
on innovation creativity.
And I want to infuse that back into
the company actually, across the globe.
And that was kind of the start of
designing the program that we did around
design thinking, and leadership, and it's
actually one of the most popular classes,
it's not a class it's a development
program, it's probably of all time.
So it's something that's worked
out exceptionally well, so
it's a beautiful climate
there's a lot of energy here.
But Detroit is different,
Detroit you have seasons you have.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Come on.
[LAUGH]
>> But and my mother
used to say that too, but I do say just to
be telling you this I say ever and since I
spent two years out here my blood thinned
cause I'm always cold when its winter.
If its below 60 its cold.
>> [LAUGH]
>> However in saying that I do enjoy it is
a different climate.
And the midwest is a different
type of community.
And that's where I've grown up so
that's home for me, and so I do enjoy it.
Again, what I think is so
interesting about Detroit right now, and
again if you don't like the Colts,
you're not going to be happy,
I'm not going to try to put a bow on that.
But what is really exciting right now to
be in Detroit, is because the city is
going through just a complete renaissance,
and it's fun to be a part of that.
It's fun to see the new
restaurants start up, and
the new cultural things that you can do.
And just to be a part of how
we're reinvigorating the city,
the entrepreneurship.
People coming to the town to
watch the new buildings come up.
You know, I joked about the fact that they
built a Whole Foods in downtown Detroit,
which five years ago people
would've been like, no.
But they built a Whole Foods and
the biggest problem with the Whole Foods
is the parking lot's not big enough.
Because, when you look at all the young
professionals that have come into
the city, when they work all day,
it's part of their routine.
So, it's really fun to be a part of a city
that's going through this rebirth and
to be a part of it.
And the other thing, why we're
drawing a lot of entrepreneurs there
is because it's pretty
cheap to live there.
So you can start a new business,
you can launch something.
So, I love it here but I love it there.
>> That makes sense.
And if we now go,
just ahead in your career,
you became CEO, there were other
internal candidates in the running.
They changed from peers to becoming
people that reported in to you.
How did you handle that transition?
>> Well, I think first of all,
we had a strong relationship before.
We had worked together before, and I have
a very collaborative leadership style,
so I want to get the best
views on the table.
And I think, because we knew each other so
well, it wasn't like I said something and
then everybody froze.
And I want people to challenge me.
I'm going to, you know, come at an issue,
and if I've got a point of view I'm going
to come at it pretty hard and
be pretty convicted.
But, if someone presents a compelling
counterpoint, I want to hear that.
And so I try to make sure there's
a lot of constructive tension, and
that all views are heard.
There's times on really important
decisions where I go to every single
person around the table and
say, what do you think?
And I've also done work with my senior
leadership team to build trust.
We actually do off sites
two to three times a year.
Well we go in to make sure,
we know how to give each other
constructive negative feedback and
have a direct conversation why I don't
agree with you and it's not personal.
So I think because that's my style
of being pretty collaborative,
we were able to work
through it pretty quickly.
There was a probably a couple
little where you kind of had
a re-negotiate how the relationship
was going to work but,
I would say a weeks, maybe a few
months in it was kind of a nonissue.
>> That's a collaborative style is that
partly because of the experience you had,
the GSP as well the offsite you have
talked about sound like some of
the courses that we do here.
Was that like big part of
the collaborative style that you used?
>> I think it's a good question,
I mean I learned so much here.
I always say when people ask me,
what did you learn,
I didn't know what I didn't know.
I had an engineering background,
I had worked in a big company,
but more in a focused area.
And so, it was so
broadening to come here and understand
the several aspects of business, so
it's always been a foundation for me.
But I think it probably does route back
to all those group projects you're doing
now where you could probably write
the paper a little faster, but
it wouldn't be as good because it
wouldn't be fusing together four views or
having those debates about, what's better?
And I think you're right.
I think that it takes more time,
but in the end you get,
i think a much better answer that you can
then execute, because the other thing is,
once you go through that
process of debating,
everybody's on board, you know,
if you're doing it well,
you get everyone on board and
then you execute a lot faster.
>> Then right at the time
you did become CEO you had
to immediately handle the faulty
ignition switch crisis.
And how, if you had been CEO before that
rather than in the direct aftermath,
was there anything you
could've done differently?
Or any changes that you
could of made to avoid it.
>> Yeah,
clearly if we'd known about it sooner
we've could of made better decisions.
But one of the things that I think is
not well known from the way that it was
covered in the media was
this was an issue that was
unfortunate that over a long
period of time mistakes were made.
But it was the internal company.
And actually the team who finally
figured out what was happening and
brought the issue forward, and
we decided to do the recall so.
But clearly there were a lot of mistakes
made along the way and, you know,
I don't know.
The minute we found out about it,
we acted.
And the minute we knew,
we were guided by three principles,
of doing the right thing for
the customer, being transparent.
And doing everything in our power to
make sure it never happened again,
which meant changing a lot of
processes and the way work was done.
And so, I think it's one of those things,
you don't get to choose
when you have a crisis.
When you have it, you have to deal with it
then, and you don't get to put it off and
say I'll deal with it next month.
You deal with it now, because that's
just the way the world works.
>> And throughout that time,
you made a significant effort to rebuild
General Motor's image with increase
number of public appearances, and so on.
How did you consider trying to
be proactive verses reactive in
that time of crisis?
>> I think you have to be proactive
because especially with how fast
communications happen today
If you don't tell if you
don't get the facts out on the table that
void will be filled with misinformation.
And so we thought it was very important
that's why transparency was one of
the kind of guiding principles we use
to make sure we will be [INAUDIBLE] at
the same time, you can't answer
questions you don't know the answer to.
And so, there were times where
I had to say, I don't know.
And, you know, I was criticized for
that when I went to Congress.
You know, even made fun of
on Saturday night live, but,
that's a fun thing to wake up to.
[LAUGH] And my brother calling me, Mary!
Mary!
I'm like.
My gosh.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But, you don't really you have
to tell the story and you have to answer
the questions when you know the answer.
One of the things and
I encourage all of you, cause your so
tempted because you think
you know what happened.
Had I done that I would
have answered wrong.
And I would've probably caused
a lot more harm to the company.
So you want to get to the facts
as quickly as you can but
if you don't have facts you can't,
it's this rationing,
because you got to move as fast as you
can but you have to do it with facts.
And for me the way I worked
on that was to have a cross
functional team that kind of had,
here's the engineering view, and
the finance view, and the legal view,
and the communications view.
And the customer sales view,
let's all get in a room and
let's figure out what are we all hearing,
what do we need to do, what are the facts,
are you sure, okay,
now we're going to move.
>> And now as you look back over your
career, one of the quotes that I saw
as we were preparing for this was
that you've never asked for a raise.
And if you were now at the start
of that career journey,
would you think about that differently?
>> I guess the way I look at it, it
kind of gets back to what I said before.
If you don't love your job, if you don't
think you're being fairly compensated, or
challenged, or it's not a fulfilling job,
you need to act on that.
I think I found through my career,
pay wasn't one of the issues that I had.
I wasn't saying never do it, I'm just
saying I found myself in a position where
there were times I had to ask for
say, hey, I know this is my job now.
And I'm going to do this really well,
but here are where my interests are and
I'd like to have the opportunity to
be considered for roles in this area.
I think that's your obligation and
I did proactively advocate for
myself in those types of situations.
I just never had an issue where I thought
I wasn't being fairly compensated.
>> Good, and final question from me
now before we open up to the audience.
Also as part of the research, we read
about your sort of never happier than
actually on the test track,
putting the cars through the paces.
Is there anything else we would be
potentially surprised to know about?
>> [LAUGH]
>> Probably [LAUGH].
But no just from a work perspective,
again, people say,
why did you stay at General Motors so
long?
There is something about
the auto industry.
And there's been a couple times
now where we've had people leave
the industry and come back.
And when I'm interviewing, I'll say,
so why do you want to come back?
And they'll be, because I miss it.
because there's just an excitement about
building cars, or trucks, or crossovers.
And people name them and
they write songs about them, and
they pick it because this fits my
personality or this fits my functionality.
But for a lot of people a car is kind
of an extension of themselves and
it's fun to be in that business.
And then, I feel like we're
in the technology business,
we're in the fashion business,
and so I just love the industry.
And I would say my best days are either
spending time at design staff,
because then you're looking at what
is the next generation of this?
Or, what is the all new vehicle
in this segment going to be?
The minute I see it,
I'm why is that two years out?
I want it now.
Or getting to spend time in
our Milford proving grounds or
some of the test tracks we have around
the world, and drive in our vehicles.
And when I was running
product development,
every Friday afternoon we'd go
out to our proving grounds.
And we'd drive our new cars, or
cars that were under development,
we'd drive it against the competition.
And we'd spend the afternoon and
it's what we do.
So it's a lot of fun.
>> Amazing, well,
this by now then look to my colleagues.
>> Hi, my name is Maurine Gauge Capello,
and I'm a MBA two here.
We talk a lot about culture
at Stanford and I wonder for
you, you're kind of leading GM through
this merger of cultures of an automotive
world that is kind of slower returns,
longer cycles, a lot of capital.
Versus like this technology innovation,
cycle of high returns, quick innovation,
and I'm curious how you think about
leading a company through that and
merging those two cultures together?
>> Yeah, one of the ways to do
that is to bring in talent.
We brought in a lot of talent who
understood the vehicle development cycle
that you talked about,
the longer capital intensive cycle.
But really to do it quickly,
you had to bring people in.
And you had to get them in the room and
get them debating it and
coming up with the right answer.
Because you can do certain things
especially in the vehicle.
When you look at all the things you can
do in a vehicle now with connecting
your phone and
all that different technology.
Or just the different functionality better
word that you can do in a car now that you
couldn't do five or ten years ago.
But how that work speed,
how you're technically doing that and
still protecting the braking and
the steering system, but
providing all this functionality.
And most people don't understand, they'll
be like, well, why can't I control this?
Well, that's pretty core to
the engine performance type of thing.
So, but
getting the two mindsets in the room and
coming up with the winning solution is
the best way to do it fast, I've found.
And then just from a culture perspective,
to me when I look at culture
it's about behaviors.
So when people ask me what
are you most worried about?
I'm confident we have good answers but
will we get them to market fast enough?
And so, constantly re-emphasizing the
speed, but yet you can't, you sometimes,
an organization, especially an engineering
organization will take you so
literally, that you have to make sure
that you're talking about safety.
One of the things we always say, we want
results, but we want it with integrity.
And so, it's really, to me,
talking a lot about behaviors.
But when you're trying to blend two very
different worlds, it's pretty hard to
take this person and or this person and
switch them and have that be successful.
But you put them together and
they can be really powerful.
>> [COUGH] Jim Phelps, MBA 79.
>> [LAUGH]
[APPLAUSE].
>> No cane, no walker.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Going back to the breadth
versus depth conversation
that you had a while back.
I wondered if you might be able
to comment on the increasing push
at both the undergraduate and
graduate level to focus,
be more capable the moment you come out.
Commit and pick majors earlier.
In graduate school, get concentrations
that are more finely tuned.
And contrast that with the recent
comments by Sam Palmisano,
the recently retired chairman and
head of another technical company, IBM.
[COUGH] That he says, I think we
have a need for more breadth for
people that can communicate,
can be cross disciplinary.
How do you see that working
out at a firm like GM and what
can you say to the student body that's
facing these sorts of questions right now?
>> It's really interesting.
Again, from a company perspective,
I need people who have tremendous depth.
If you're a chief engineer of a vehicle,
that's generally,
by the time you get to be a chief you've
been in that vehicle development,
being on a product program for
about 15 years.
Because the cycles of learning, really
being able to make all of the decisions to
integrate every single
system in the vehicle.
The way we do it, it's a really small
team that is the chief engineer, and
then the electrical group, and
the power train group, and
the body structures group, and the
infotainment, they're all coming together.
But they're the ones that have
got to make those tradeoffs so.
And there are certain areas where
we just need tremendous staff.
And then there's areas where you need
somebody say, yeah, I understand this but
I do need the breadth because
you need to make the trade offs.
So it's kind of you need to make
the trade offs this way or this way.
That's why I say you need both.
And I'm going to answer the second
part of it as a mom though.
So I have a sophomore in college and
a high school senior.
And I just, we are just asking.
I go back, and not that we can
go back to when I was a kid.
But how can you know
when you're 16 years old,
exactly what you want to do for
the rest of your life?
I'm not sure I know what I want to do
at age 55, for the rest of my life.
So I think there's a need to,
if you're studying engineering,
to still have some broadening classes and
some,
from a From a liberal arts perspective,
or the liberal arts school,
or to understand philosophy,
I think it makes you a better engineer.
So this, I'm only going to do this,
and I'm going to focus, and
I'm going to be the best
person on this one technology.
It's one thing if you make that
decision once you get into your career.
I remember one of the most valued people
when I was running the manufacturing
engineering group with my welding expert.
And he had spent his career
becoming a welding expert.
And grew into that role and that's the
kind of depth I'm talking about you need.
But he probably made that decision
in his thirties or forties.
Not at 16, 17, 18, when you're
picking an undergraduate major.
So I'm a big proponent that
as you're at a university,
yes, if you know for
sure this is what you want to do.
I still think you should get
some broadening classes and
challenge yourself to think
a little differently.
If you don't know, that's okay!
And then you need to take a broad sweep.
So again, I have one child who knows
exactly what he wants to do, and
I have another who doesn't.
And I'm telling them both, take some of
those classes that are going to broaden.
That you're not sure about because, again,
I came here thinking I was
kind of checking a box.
And I didn't know what I didn't know.
So it scares me how we're pretty soon
you're going to be in middle school and
have to declare a career so.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Christoph Meyer MBA two I'd
love to hear your perspectives.
So many companies have entered the
automotive space including tech companies.
What competitor keeps you up at night?
>> Well, I like to describe
ourself as a tech company.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Tens of millions of lines of code in
every vehicle, but okay.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But to your point, they all scare me.
It's my job to be paranoid about that.
I mean, there are some incredibly,
when you look at the big players in the,
I'll say in the traditional sense,
the OEMs, they're very capable.
Whether you're talking about Asian
competitors, or German competitors,
Korean competitor, very capable,
so they keep me up at night.
And then when you look at the resources
that some of the Apples, and the Googles,
and some of the startups can bring.
I mean we bought a startup because, and
we made that decision could we
have grown that talent inside?
Probably, it was a heck of a lot faster
to take somebody who had been working on
it a couple years and then marry
the two and find the right power.
So whether it's the big tech companies,
or the traditional OEMs, or
the startups, they all worry me.
And that's my job to
worry about all of that.
>> Alex Minkey, MBA one, I was curious to
get your thoughts on the growth of EV's,
head winds and tail winds.
How fast your expecting them to grow and
GM strategy within that.
>> So from a electric vehicle perspective,
I think it's definitely part
of the future solution.
When you look at the environmental
concerns, it's absolutely a must.
As are fuel cells, and
we invest heavily in both.
I think EVs will come first
kind of down the learning curve.
Because we're still working on solving the
kind of the energy density issues around
batteries, and the cost issues.
Although, we had tremendous learnings
from our first generation Volt,
to our second generation Volt,
to now the Chevrolet Volt.
I keep seeing the costs come down and
the energy density go up.
So I believe we're close, in fact, General
Motors we have put out externally I said
we have challenged ourself
to be the first OEM or
company that has profitable electric
vehicles that are affordable.
Because we believe it's so
much a part of the future.
The biggest volume is going to first be
in China because they're regulating it.
And when you look at the size
of the Chinese market,
last year it was 28
million new vehicles sold.
Whether it's 18, 19, or 20,
10% of that market by mandate.
Well, 10, 12, 14% will be electric or
either fully ED or a plug in hybrid.
So definitely moving here, there's
a part that's an emotional decision and
then for the bulk of people who buy
vehicles, there's a financial decision.
And with low gas prices, it makes
the equation even a little bit harder.
But I believe, five years, it'll be
significantly more across the globe.
A lot of it does depend on fuel prices.
But I think it's a trend and
a very important technology that we have
to continue to develop aggressively,
because it's so important from
an environmental perspective.
>> Hi Mary, Jeff Howe, MBA one.
You have a particularly vocal and
public investor in your company right now,
who's indicated he's not 100% in
agreement with everything GM is deciding.
I was just curious to hear from you how
you think about managing that dialogue?
And also how you think about shareholders
in the context of all stakeholders in GM?
>> Well, shareholders are our owners,
so they're vitally important.
And that's why we spent so
much time on this particular issue,
to look to see hey is
there a good idea here?
Because our job is to do the best,
responsibly, for our share holders.
And as we evaluated this issue,
we didn't think it was in the best
interest of our share holders.
And so
I talk regularly to multiple shareholders,
just two days ago I was in Boston
meeting with several shareholders.
Spent the day, and
I do that quite regularly.
So I think it's very important
to listen to your shareholders,
to understand their points of views.
But at the same time then we have
to take all that information and
integrate it and then understand,
because we're at the company day in and
day out, and understand.
Maybe at a level deeper because
we spend 24/7 on it and so
we've gotta look at what's
the right decision.
Let's take all that input now and
let's understand what we're doing.
Is there a way we can
improve our strategy?
Is there a different capital
allocation decision we can make?
We've always gotta stay open to that,
because not every good idea is going to
necessarily come from the company.
So that's the way I hugely
value my shareholders,
and feel it's vitally important to
listen to them on a very regular basis.
>> Hi, Shan you, class of 07.
And also a GM shareholder.
>> Thank you.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I have a question about automated cars.
Assuming that the future includes
automated cars talking to each other
through a protocol, my question is how
do you think we're going to get there?
Do you think the market's going to pick
a winner among OEMs or tech companies,
traditional tech companies?
Or do you think government's going to
set a standard or play a role?
>> Well I think if you're going to have
the vehicle to vehicle communications
which we actually have a vehicle
that has a capability on it now.
It's pretty limited
because it's one model.
I think the government has to play a role.
And there's already a standard set and
a spectrum dedicated to it.
But I think what's happening because,
think about it,
every car has gotta have the technology.
The car park right now in
the United States is 240 million vehicles.
And at a rate of a pretty strong market
now of 17.5 million vehicles a year,
it's a long journey to have
fully v to v capability.
Although there's probably
some things you can do, but
then of adding the technology
to other vehicles, certainly.
So I think that's a part as we go,
and it's v to v, v to i,
v to infrastructure as well.
But I think what's happening
in autonomous vehicles now
because that's a longer journey.
Really to do an autonomous vehicle, to
control it, you need to know three things.
Precisely where am I?
Precisely what's happening around me?
And therefore, third,
what path do I take safely?
And we're doing that
with other technologies.
But clearly the V2V and the V2I
technology, I think, down the road,
has it to take it to even another level
of not only safety, but efficiency, but
we're a ways off.
Hi
>> My name is Catherine Morgan.
I'm in MBA 1.
When you guys were talking about
the roles that cars have played in
American culture really resonated
with me because I'm from Texas.
And so I was wondering if you can comment
a little bit about how you see the role
of cars and
maybe more specifically GM playing
in the next generation of Americana.
>> Well, again,
as I started the conversation,
I think it's our job to not say here
customers the solution for you, but
to listen to the customer and
say what does technology enable us to do?
How our city's changing,
how our transportation changing and
then provide the most efficient best
solution from a customer's perspective.
So, I think one of the key things we
need to do is really understand what
the technology's capable of doing,
not only and a wholly world one
of the time this vehicles of what do you
do when the vehicle because you solve and
you haven't you know at least for
period time the physical time of
getting from point a to point b.
How do we make that more efficient?
How do we make the environment,
what you're able to do?
I mean that's why it's so exciting right
now to be in the auto business, or
the transportation business
because it's really,
we have to be customer driven in
how we deploy the technology most
efficiently because I
think that's who wins.
>> Good afternoon.
Sort of saying, MSX program,
when you got into GM,
the way I looked at it, it was starting
up a hundred year old company.
What were your biggest challenges
when you get into that role and
you had to like jump start something
that's been around for so long.
>> Are you talking about
when I became the CEO?
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
I had been part of the leadership,
the senior leadership team for
a handful of years before I had
the opportunity to be the CEO.
So we were already working on transforming
the culture, simplifying the company,
eliminating bureaucracy, making sure
people were empowered to do their best.
So I'd been kind of been on that journey.
So a lot of it was continuing and
accelerating the work that we
were doing to kind of, I'll say,
push the reset the button after
the bankruptcy with the company.
And a lot of it really gets to behaviors.
So if you subscribe that most
people come to work everyday and
they want to do a good job,
what's getting in their way?
Do we have an environment and
a collaborative environment and
the tools that are necessary so
you can do your best work?
Or is it painful to get
the most simple tasks done.
And so, a lot of it is just continuing
to make sure that processes and
systems were efficient and
we're giving people the right tools and
we're giving them the right training and
then empowering them.
And that's the journey we've been on,
I would say,
since even before I had the role and
continue to do that today.
We spend a lot of time working
on what are the right behaviors,
what are the company's values,
and how do we really infuse that,
because then it gets to that
capturing the hearts and
minds of everybody that are going
to deliver superior results.
Unfortunately that is all we have time for
so please join me and thank you very much.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Thank you all, great questions.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]